No, a lie is when you when you present
something that's untrue. What's true is
that he wasn't
and all what and what did Allah make
appear?
That he was crucified.
So he lied.
No, thank you.
He didn't lie because he the thing is is
in the the what God did was what he did.
Okay. So what's the question?
Well, the statement is that Allah made
me believe in a crucifixion.
Okay. So we in Islam we believe in free
will. So you you made that decision.
Nope. Allah made it appear that uh that
he was that he was crucified and so
therefore you know
well that's true.
But the decision to fall for that was
yours.
Can I res resist Allah's trick? If he
wants to delude me can I resist that?
Can you resist it? Yeah. You have free
will. You can resist anything.
No. The Quran says that Allah guides
proof do you have? Yeah. But okay,
that's true.
But what proof do you have that that you
can't uh you didn't have free choice in
that situation?
Am I able to resist Allah's delusion? If
he wants to delude me, can I resist his
delusion? I
I don't know why you're calling it a
delusion. You're kind of you're you're
just at this point mocking. But
the point is the point is that you have
free will. So in surah gahif
29 it says the truth is from your lord.
So whoever wills let him believe and
whoever wills let him disbelieve.
Yeah. And chapter 14:4 says do not
basically don't trip over those who
reject the message because Allah guides
who he wants and he misguides who he
wants.
Yeah. I mean but that's that's
when taken into context. When taken.
Let me finish please. And then it goes
on to say, you cannot guide those who
Allah misguided. Is that free will?
Yeah, 100% it's free will because you're
taking it out of context. The people who
are misguided are misguided because they
have arrogance in their heart. So they
they made the initial decision to be
misguided is what you're
misunderstanding. This is this is
unanimous amongst all. Why does it say
that Muhammad has the has no capability
of guiding them because Allah misguided
them?
The point of that is that the prophet
Muhammad is a warner. He has no control
over who accepts the message and who
rejects it.
Yeah, but that's not answering the
question.
No, that is
why does he have no capability of
guiding them according to the
Sorry.
What is the reason why he has no
capability of guiding those people?
because he doesn't he doesn't nobody has
the ability to uh
there's a reason the verse gives a
reason
right and I'm telling you you're taking
that reason out of context but that's a
whole another discussion I I'm answering
your question your question is Allah
made me believe the I'm telling you that
we in Islam we believe in free will and
your free will with your free will you
chose to believe
that that you don't have free will in
Islam you don't you're wrong
I just quoted you a verse that says we
do. I can quote you.
I just quoted you a verse that
contradicts that. So now what what do we
do?
What? And I just explained that verse to
you. People choose misguidance and and
doesn't say that they chose misguidance.
It says Allah misguided them.
And I just gave you a verse that says
who whoever disbelieves let him
disbelieve. It's from their own their
it's from their will their own their
own.
The verse says that their disbelief
comes from Allah. that Allah is the one
who misguides the
time with the verse. The verse is the
truth is from your Lord. So whoever
wills let him believe and whoever wills
says Allah misguides who he wills and he
guides who he wills. Don't cry over
those. Don't weep over those that
disbelieve because you cannot guide
those who Allah misguided. Okay. He's
talking specifically to the prophet
Muhammad that it is not in that human
being's power to make uh a anybody
believe or disbelieve. Which is true.
It's not in his power.
But why?
Because only God can do that.
Uh-huh. So only God is the one who can
make someone believe.
Only God is the one who makes people
what?
No, God can do that. According to the
verse, let's stay consistent with the
verse. Let's stay consistent.
According to the verse, only God is the
one who makes people believe. And only
God is the one who makes people
No. Uh only God can do that. Yes.
Yeah. Only God can do that. Yes.
No, it's not only God can do that. It's
that that's what he does.
No.
It says Allah guides who he wants and he
misguides who he wants. You cannot guide
who Allah misguided.
Yeah. Because it because at the end of
the day, we believe in the end of the
day, baby. At the end of the day,
let me explain it. Don't interrupt me.
At the end of the day, the day going to
end.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, I hear you.
I'm messing with you, man. Go ahead.
The thing is is as Muslims, we believe
in free will and we believe in divine
decree, right? So everything that
happens has to happen at the will of
God, right? And that's that's pretty
much that's that's the only way you can
believe in God's divine plan and free
will at the same time. So that that
should be true for you as well. And and
as a Muslim, you we our will is subject
to God's will. But ultimately, if God
doesn't will for it to happen, doesn't
allow it to happen, it can't happen.
Gotcha. So, um, it looks like we're not
going to get anywhere with this. Let me
switch the angle up here. The reason why
I I'm going still go with Allah made me
believe it, but according to to what
you're saying, I chose to believe in the
delusion that Allah placed in front of
us that Jesus was crucified.
Yeah. I mean, well, you weren't there.
You chose to believe what people said,
right? So, people who were there saw
Jesus being crucified. However, it
wasn't true. It wasn't truly Jesus being
crucified, but Allah made them made them
see that. They made them think that
he made it he made it appear that way.
Yeah.
Right. So the this whole idea that Jesus
was crucified comes from Allah in the
first place. Right.
As does pretty much everything else like
the existence of the devil.
Okay. But so so you're saying that both
lies and truth comes from Allah.
It's not is not a lie. How is that a
lie? It happened. God can't lie. It
happened. You calling it a lie is not is
is is a mis misqualifying.
Well, let's see. Let's see.
We're classifying it.
Let's work it out together. Was Jesus
truly crucified?
Was he crucified? No. No. No. Notified.
Not on my not based on my belief. Yeah.
Right. Right. Right. So, he wasn't
crucified. So now if Allah then comes
[clears throat] and portrays Jesus to be
when he's not being crucified.
Yeah.
So that it's it's false that Jesus was
crucified. The truth is that he wasn't.
The falsehood is that he was crucified
and this falsehood was portrayed by
Allah himself. Right. It
it's not a falsehood though, dude. That
your That's your understanding of it.
You're calling it a falsehood is miscl
classifying what happened.
So let me give you an example. Let me
give you an example just so we're on the
same page. Right? In the battle of Bedr,
God sent angels down to help the
Muslims, right? So the the the
non-believers, they believed they were
outnumbered, right? Because they were
outnumbered. Although they couldn't see
the the Muslims couldn't see that,
right?
They were outed though. The point is
that it's not it's not it's not the
Allah telling a lie that's that goes
against the essence of a god. God can't
what what what is the what is what is
the opposite of truth?
Sorry. Hold on. Go ahead. I got no
worries.
What is the opposite of truth?
The opposite of truth is a lie. No.
Could be wrong about that, but I I don't
know. I mean, it sounds philosophical
question.
You're right.
I'm sure that's not even the right
answer, but go ahead. It is the right
answer.
Well, I mean that's what you think, but
I I think that if we actually look that
up, it may not be the right answer.
The opposite of truth is lie is a lie.
It's falsehood. Okay. So, when something
is not true, then it is false. Right.
So, are you saying the opposite of truth
or the opposite of I mean the oppos
opposite of truth is false. It doesn't
mean a lie.
No, no worries. You're right. Lie comes
with intention. Like someone is do
like a lie would be somebody purposely
giving falsehood. Right.
Right. Right. Right.
So that would be that lie has to do with
intention. So if someone intends to give
falsehood then that means they're lying.
Would you agree?
If somebody intends to give false
information that would be a lot shorter.
All right. All right. Cool. So we're
we're working together.
Yeah.
All right. So the opposite of truth is
falsehood.
And a lie is someone who intentionally
gives false information in order to
deceive. All right.
This is where we're at. It's not true
that Jesus was crucified.
Yeah.
Right. So it's it's false that Jesus was
crucified.
It's false that
Yeah. It's false that Jesus was
crucified. That's false. Allah portrayed
that Jesus was crucified. No, but your
your belief in what happened could be
true or false. God what actually
happened is what is true. God didn't
make something false or make you that's
not how it works. Your It's your
perception which is what's true or
false. Not what God did. God didn't do
falsehood. God did something and you you
didn't believe it.
Got you. When it says it was made to
appear, so it was made to appear that he
was crucified.
Yeah. Yeah.
What does that mean?
It means that it was exactly what it
says.
Who made it appear that Jesus was
crucified?
God did.
All right. Is it true that Jesus was
crucified or false that he was?
It is it true that Jesus was not
crucified?
All right. So it's it's it's false then
to say that Jesus was crucified.
Yeah. So, so Allah made it appear that
Jesus was crucified. So, he made it
appear that a falsehood took place. He
brought falsehood into the mix.
Yeah. I mean, that that that No, wait,
wait, wait. God made it appear that
that Jesus was crucified.
Okay.
That's that's the reality, right?
The reality is that he wasn't crucified.
Allah went against reality and made and
how can God go against reality?
Well, he presented a falsehood. He
presented something that wasn't true. It
was it's not true that Jesus was
crucified. This is a falsehood that was
portrayed by Allah. Right?
Listen, God put down the truth, which is
that Jesus would not be crucified. You
chose to believe that he was still
crucified.
Well, well, God is the one who Allah is
the one who made it appear that Jesus
was crucified, right?
Yes.
All right. So, if Allah is the one who
made it appear that Jesus was crucified,
he portrayed a false a false thing.
Something true.
I'm not going to I'm not going to agree
with you on the wording, dude. I agree
on it con because it's just not true.
Because God is the truth. He can't he
he's not going to be false. And you're
making it seem like he lied and he
didn't lie.
You're right on the money. I I don't
mean to cut you off, but you're right on
the money. God, the true God, will not
be false, portray something as false, or
present anything that's false because
God, the true God, in his nature is
truth. He cannot lie. He cannot be
false. He cannot be uh, you know,
anything like that. This is why I reject
Islam because it paints Allah as a liar
who presented falsehood to people and
deceived many people. That's why he's
not the true God.
He didn't falsehood is what your point
my point is.
Yes. He he betrayed all this falsehood
which is why I reject Islam.
It's only false because you think it's
false. It's true to God. No, you you and
I both agree. You and I both agree that
Jesus that according to Islam, Jesus was
not crucified. So to say that he was
crucified would be false.
Yes.
So Allah portrayed that Jesus was
crucified. So he's portraying falsehood
which is something God cannot do. You
get what I'm saying?
No. God can't be false. Okay. And
right and God Right. But that what what
you're what you're considering false.
God never did. God simply made it appear
that Jesus was crucified. Right? That is
the truth. Okay. Now, you believe that
he was crucified. So, what you believe
is false. What your perception is is
false.
Okay. All right, man. Uh I think that
we're at a point where you you see what
I'm saying. And the the how can I say
this? The things that you're hesit that
you're like really hesitant to
acknowledge and admit are the things
that I'm not hesitant to admit. I'm not
afraid to admit those things. Which
leads me to the conclusion that Islam is
false. You're hesitant to admit these
things because obviously you know that
that would lead to the conclusion that
Islam is false cuz God can't be a liar.
He can't be false. He can't do any of
that.
He can't be a liar. But where did he
lie?
By by making it seem like Jesus was
crucified when he was.
That's not him lying though.
That is him lying. H
how?
Because he's intentionally uh presenting
false information in order to deceive
the people.
But but that if that were true, he's
still not lying.
That is lying. We both agree that that's
what lying is when you lying is
intention, right? It's when you
intentionally
present false information. when you you
false to who?
Reality, bro. Like like it's just
falsehood and truth are based on
reality. So reality whatever is you know
but the thing is no no
whatever is congruent with reality
that's what truth is. Whatever goes
against reality that's what falsehood
is. Now, if I come and give you
something, if I present to you something
false intentionally, I know that it's
false, yet I'm going to present it to
you anyway, as if it's true. I'm a liar,
right?
No. What what I'm saying is that that
No, no, no, no, no. You're you're you're
wrong here because
because you're saying that he presented
No, a lie is when you when you present
something that's untrue. What's true is
that he wasn't
and Allah what and what did Allah make
appear?
That he was crucified.
So he lied.
No, thank you.
He didn't lie because he the thing is is
in the the what God did was what he did.
How you choose to to portray that is is
a lie.
Come on, man.
No. No. It It's true. It It's
You can say that you were deceived, but
that doesn't mean that you were lied to.
Come on, man.
Because what actually happened? What
actually happened? Jesus wasn't
crucified. Now, if Jesus was crucified
and God told you he wasn't crucified, he
would be lying to you. He didn't lie to
you.
Come on, man. What were we doing here,
dog?
Okay. I mean, you can say that as many
times as you want. You still haven't
proven how he lied.
You know what? You're right, man. I
ain't I haven't proven I haven't proven
anything. So, with that being said, big
dog, I think we could go ahead and and
end it, man.
All right.
I appreciate you coming.
Yeah. No, it was good talking to you,
man. All right.
Good talking to you, man. You can come
back anytime, man.
All right. Take care.